انتقل احمد مع عائلته للسكن في مخيم
بالقرب من بيته المدمر في مدينه انطاكيا
املا بحصوله على تعويض عاجل بدلا من ان
يغادر المدينه يتحضر وسكان المخيم
للمشاركه في الانتخابات التركيه المقبله
في وقت تقوم الاحزاب السياسيه بحملات
انتخابيه خجوله وسط الدمار الذي ملا شوارع
المدينه
السياسه لم تعد تهمنا الحكومه ممكنه ان
تتغير لكن الوطن باقن بالتالي نحن الاتراك
وكل من يعيش في دولتنا يجب ان يكون همنا
المشترك حب الوطن والحفاظ عليه وطن
من الركام الى صناديق الاقتراع في هاتاي
التي تسيطر عليها ايديولوجيات تاريخيه
وانتماءات حزبيه تدفع السكان للاصطفاف
السياسي مع الاحزاب المتنافسه على السلطه
زادت كارثه الزلزال
التسبث الاتراك
بخياراتهم وانتماءاتهم مله قردشتر الشاب
واخوه لكن السياسه فرقتنا فرحانيه وهذه
المنطقه يعطون اصواتهم لاردوغان لكن اذا
انتقلنا الى المنطقه الساحليه فاحبتنا
واقاربنا هناك يعطون اصواتهم للاحزاب
المعارضه يجب ان لا تفرق بيننا الانتخابات
اذهبوا الى الانتخابات واعطوا صوتكم لمن
تحبون كم يساوي
شهدتها تدميرا واسعا بفعل الزلزال الذي
جعل اكثر من 90% من منازلها ضمن قائمه
الهدم استمرت الاحزاب السياسيه بتراشق
الاتهامات على ان تنظم مدينه مدمره في وقت
ينتظر السكان لملمه الجراح وجبر الضرر
بالرغم ان الوالي والبلديات يتبعون
للحكومه فقدنا الكثير من الاشخاص تحت
الانقاض بسبب التقصير والتاخير والحكومه
تتظاهر بالحزن لخداعنا سينعكس ذلك على
الانتخابات بالتاكيد تشير توقعاته الى
استمرار سيطره المعارضه على النسبه الاعلى
في انتخابات هاتاي بينما يبدي الناخبون
مخاوفهم من عدم قدره الاحزاب السياسيه على
الايثاء بوعودهم خلال الفتره المقبله بسبب
حجم الدمار والخسائر الكبيره في المدينه
لا صوت هنا يعلو فوق صوت الموت والدمار
ترك الزلزال اثاره في كل شيء حتى اصوات
الناخبين المترددين المراقبين لاجراءات
الحكومه ما بعد الكارثه مسلم السيد عيسى
العربيه مدينه انطاكيا جنوبيه تركيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقاري ر
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات